foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
is to make consistent our policy
we have to help
support this conference
in order to fight against poverty and
equalities to deal with climate change
and to fight against terrorism
no doubt about that we have to help them
for Education agricultural economic
opportunities no doubt about that so I
think the sequence we started with the
African Union European Union Summit
remains very valid and has to be
delivered at the same time we have to
better protect our external borders
and sometimes it's very difficult for
public opinion and societies to
understand that you can help countries
you can provide visa and at the same
time they tell you I cannot control my
the people when they arrive and I don't
want to take them back when you have
problem with them
so it's a normal political dialogue I
would not put it as something I would
say incompatible with this approach and
by the way one year ago we discussed
about migration as well positive
migration but as well the migration we
want to limit and better control and I
think what is at stake in is the
European Union and the debate we will
have is how to better protect our
borders
and how to better integrate
people when they arrive and they want to
stay here for two main reasons one
because there are Fighters for for
freedom
and asking for Asylum second when they
ask to work in our societies and
contribute to our prosperity
no but we have this political dialogue I
don't I wouldn't make it now as a
but I do believe that we have to improve
our dialogue with the origin country and
I think it's much more efficient than
trying to push back in the third
countries and having this type of
approach but for me the conclusions we
have and what the commission proposed is
extremely useful and very valid
and I think we have to improve our
common policy vis-a-vis these countries
of origin in order to reduce
foreign
thank you
everything
foreign
thank you
baby
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
everything
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the presence of a crane is Excellency
follow the mirsky
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
occasion to welcome the president of
Ukraine volodimir zielinski to the
European Parliament
this is an extraordinary moment in
extraordinary times it has been almost
one year since the brutal illegal
invasion of sovereign Ukraine by Russia
in all that time Mr President your
leadership has inspired your people and
inspired every corner of the globe
when the world thinks of Ukraine they
think of the heroes fighting the odds
of David beating Goliath
they think of the icons of snake island
the Warriors of marupol the liberators
of so many occupied towns and Villages
their names will be spoken of for
Generations
notwithstanding the bombs that fall
every day your grain continues to feed
the world
when a devastating earthquake hits
turkey and Syria you stood up and sent
Rescuers equipment and expertise that is
real solidarity
I am I am proud to say that this house
of European democracy its members our
European Union has always stood with you
we understand that you are fighting not
only for your values but for ours
for those ideals that bind us as sisters
and brothers
they make us all European because
Ukraine is Europe and your nature
nation's future is in the European Union
foreign
we know the sacrifice that your people
have endured for Europe and we must
honor it not only be with words but with
action with the political will to ensure
easier trade and with the fastest
possible accession process with funds
for your people with help in
reconstruction with training for your
troops with military equipment and
defense systems you need to win and now
states must consider quickly as a Next
Step providing long-range systems and
the Jets that you need to protect the
Liberty too many have taken for granted
our response must be proportional to the
threat and the threat is existential
I grew up hearing my grandparents
stories of my country's last three
fighter planes
when all seemed lost when they had no
ammunition no food and no hope all that
remained were the three barely
functioning planes that they called
faith hope and charity named after what
they were fighting for after what was at
stake the plains meant one more day of
Liberty just long enough for help to
arrive they meant peace you do not need
to convince anyone here of how essential
it is to support Ukraine to back all
those giving their lives to support the
values we preach with concrete measures
to ensure Victory real peace based on
your 10-point plan accountability for
those who committed war crimes and for
the protection of freedom for all
ukrainians
and I want to repeat the promise that I
made to you when we met in Kiev last
April we have your back we were with you
then
we are with you now we will be with you
for as long as it takes Freedom will
prevail peace will reign you will win
slab or crying
[Applause]
thank you
slavo green glory to Ukraine
dear
Mrs president
Roberto
I thank you
for these powerful words
and I thank you for your personal
attention very important intention to
Ukraine
thank you
for your
and your principled and energetic
approach to qualities that we see
unchanged during this struggle for
Europe
and the combination of those is a
precondition of for Progress Europe is
lucky
that in this plenary hole in the biggest
parliament of Europe
in the European Parliament
principled approach and energized
approach
have an absolute majority enjoy an
absolute majority of thank you
representatives of Europe ship dear
leaders of Europe all of us Europeans
each and every hundreds of millions of
people in our continent
combine these two statuses
representatives of Europe and leaders of
Europe this combination reflects
what our Europe
modern Europe
peaceful Europe gives to the world
European way of life
European
life standard European rules of life
when each and everyone
have matter when the law rules
the
rule of law when States strive to be
social and societies
strive to be open when a diversity is of
value
and the values of different people are
united by
Fair quality
when borders are
not violated
and but when you don't feel that you
cross-borders when people Trust
and have faith in tomorrow and they're
ready to go to squares to fight for
their tomorrow when
between protesters and the president
president there's only one barrier and
that is honest elections
this is our Europe
these are our rooms
this is our way of life
and for Ukraine
it's a way home
a way to its home
now I'm here in order to defend
uh people's way home of all ukrainians
of all ages or and various political
convictions are various social status of
various religious conviction
convictions and
different histories but all of us enjoy
this common European history
the Ukrainian European way of life they
tried to annihilate it with through
Total War
after that why because after the
European Ukrainian European way of life
they want to destroy the European
way as such of
out of all 27 elements of the European
way of life of 27 countries of the
European Union
we will not allow that
this Total War now
that was waged by Russia
is not only for the territory
for a territory in this or that part of
Europe the threat of it
is that there is a dictator with
supplies and reserves of Soviet weapons
and
weapons from dictatory regimes Iran in
particular in order to be able to fight
like this the Kremlin cynically and
deliberately year after year step after
step was trying to eliminate and destroy
what we see as our value in Europe the
value of human lives has been destroyed
in Russia for the authorities there
nobody is of value apart from those who
are in the Kremlin and have their own
wallets as
at heart 140 million of Russian citizens
for the leaders of Russia are just
bodies uh that are capable of carrying
weapons to Russia the weapons that would
be on the battlefield and to keep
everybody in obedience so they could
become the supremacy of violence and
obedience these are the rules
instead of
look there
the Russian regime
not only hates
any social
Justice and diversity they invest in
xenophobia and try are trying to make it
part of normality on our continent and
trying to
make
the inhumane relatives of the 30s and
the 40s the 20th century are relative
today but this is the answer to that for
us is no no Europe we are defending the
we're defending from the anti-european
most anti-european force of the modern
world we are defending ourselves we
ukrainians on the battlefield together
with you
and I thank you
that we're defending it together and we
must defend ourselves and it's important
not only for these states of Europe not
only for the communities and Societies
in Europe no matter who we are and what
we are we're always fight against
disrespect
and neglect wherever we live we're
always
put our
faith in Integrity forever for whatever
we dream for our children and
grandchildren
and the precondition for these dreams is
peace and security
and that is going to be
and whether it's going to be possible
if we do not overcome
the anti-european force that is trying
to steal from all of us
our Europe now only our victory
will guarantee all that
each of our European values
our
our victory that is going to be
that should be should happen that would
be mandatory dear leaders of Europe dear
president ladies and gentlemen dear
members of European dear workers of the
European Parliament here and are the
European institutions here dear
journalists
dear
Security Service workers their military
and army Personnel policeman rescue
workers dear workers and municipalities
diplomats teachers professors scientists
a dear doctors drivers dear workers of
seaports Farmers the Industrials dear
workers at the industrial Enterprise
dear business owners small
big businesses dear workers said Banks
dear energy workers and electricity
workers dear Trade union workers dear
students and representatives of ngos
dear producers and actors lawyers
defense lawyers human rights Defenders
the destiny of Europe the fate of Europe
has never depended on politicians and
that should not be the Illusions now
each and every one of us matter
each and every one of you are strong
each and every one of you is capable to
impact and influence our common result
our common victory
and
[Music]
and these Applause
are not directed to me Anatomy this
these Applause is actually for these
Applause I'd like to thank all of you in
Europe in hundreds of Thousand Villages
who supported Ukraine
in this historic battle thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I would like to thank you
to all of you who has been helping our
people our ordinary citizens our
resettled people here who called on
their leaders to increase and enhance
their support to protect our Ordinary
People those who were
on the squares who were raising
questions who was spreading truth about
the Russian aggression who was not
tempted by to consume Russian the
Russian disinformation and who's
standing by us in our fight for life for
Europe I thank you
I thank all of us who helped all of you
who helps Ukraine with vitally important
supplies weapons and ammunition and
energy equipment and fuel
thousands of things and items that would
be that we wouldn't be able to endure in
this total well I thank you ladies and
gentlemen and members of European
Parliament and to you personally Roberta
that you with your decisions
defend the European way of life without
a steadfastly that you defend the
Ukrainian European way of life
you approve courageous decisions
and you strengthen the European ambition
to be
a home for justice
and freedom and I recall the first day
of large-scale invasion when the Russian
ambition to break us and the entire
Europe was still
adamant and was still
still one day the Russian
aggression was beginning to break their
tooth against fighting our defense on
this sixth day of the large-scale
invasion European Parliament approved
the resolution not simply to support our
state but to uh
approve the status of the candidate for
the European membership for our country
that was the vision that motivates
motivated us to be uh strong and to be
to stay uh to stay the course
thank you
today
during the meeting of the Council of
European Council I'll be able to thank
personally the heads of state and the
governments for the decisions that over
the course of last year allowed our
continents to do what the previous wave
of leaders considered impossible Europe
at last is relieving itself of the
ruinous dependence on the Russian fossil
fuels Europe is cleansing itself of the
corruption influence of the Russian
oligarchic business Europe is defending
itself
from the infiltration of the Agents of
Russians secret Services who were
looking at Europe as the hunting field
for the opposition
opponents of the Russian regime for the
first time in its history the European
Union is providing the military
assistance at such large scale at such
scale and for I see such a positive uh
assessment of reforms and the European
in the European country that is fighting
defending itself and is modernizing and
reforming its institutions at the same
time we're approaching the European
Ukraine is going to be a member of the
European Ukraine
as that is winning
is going to be the member of the
European Union the European Union that
is winning
dear friends
perhaps somebody some of you didn't feel
earlier the part the powerful
uh the power the power of the European
wave life and now together Ukraine and
the European Union countries
have made our strength of this why is it
possible because we combined a princess
principled and energetic approach
we all are equal we're all equal in
representing uh Europe and integrity
we know that everybody is a leader of
Europe and there's
lives in their specific lives we
we do not do we're not going back in
front of the enemy we are defending so
we're not losing time we're changing
ourselves and we are changing
thinks Europe will always be and remain
Europe as long as we're together as long
as we take care of our Europe as we take
care of the European way of life
I thank all of you
I invite all of you
to Ukraine
glory to all ukrainians
and who who fight and glory to Ukraine
foreign
thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
thank you